>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Pam Jackson: So, good afternoon.
How are you?
[ Inaudible ]
>> I'll introduce myself
in just a moment.
So yeah, thank you for being here.
I'm Pam Jackson.
I'm the Director for the Center
for the Book here at the Library
of Congress, and I'd
like to welcome you all.
I am -- The Young Readers Center
here is a part of the Center
for the Book, and I just want
to check how many people
you're here for the first time?
Raise your hands.
So folks -- here in The Young
Readers Center, first timers.
Oh, wow. Okay, great.
And some of you it looks like
yes, you've been here before.
Yes? Oh, wow.
Okay, great.
Well, welcome and welcome back.
We are here to have a really
great discussion and book talk
so we thank you for being
here and let me find
out -- where are you from?
[ Inaudible ]
Washington School for Girls.
Washington Middle School for Girls.
Okay, I was just checking.
I knew that.
So we like to welcome you all.
And what do you think
you're here to talk about?
[ Inaudible ]
Do you know anything more than that?
That book?
How many of you have seen this?
Have you seen this before?
[ Inaudible ]
You've seen it on Amazon?
Okay, great.
And are you guys used
to talking about books?
Raise your hand.
Yes, I talk about books
all the time,
and I meet authors all the time.
Okay, great.
And so I've talked about
books occasionally.
Raise your hand.
Raise your hand if you like books.
It's okay, okay.
Yeah, all right.
And you like talking
about the ideas in books?
How many like that?
Some? Some?
Okay. Well, listen.
You guys have a really
special opportunity and part
of why we have you here is because
we hope that you'll get a lot
of value out of the conversation.
You are going to meet Ms.
Elizabeth Wein who is the author
of the book, Black
Dove, White Raven.
And it's a special book because
it's won a particular kind of award.
So it's a very beautiful story,
has very awesome characters
that are very rich and interesting.
I'm sure you can relate to them.
And she takes you a
number of different places.
It's one of the things
I like most about books.
There are tons of places in the
world that I don't have time to go
or I don't have the money to go to,
and I get to read books like this
and go to those places anyway.
And, she's received an award,
a special award that's being
celebrated this weekend
and so I want to acknowledge
[inaudible].
This part I probably have
to put my glasses on for.
So the -- she's won the
Children's Africana Book Award,
and there's a celebration
this weekend, and you'll hear
about that shortly from one of the
individuals that's with us today.
And to acknowledge what
the organization is,
it's the Outreach Council
of African Study --
the African Studies
Association that runs that award.
And with us today is Brenda
Rudolph from the organization.
So we just kind of want to let you
know that it's a special opportunity
to be with an award winning author.
She's going to do her talk first
and talk a little bit about the book
and read from the book, and
then there's going to be time
to ask her questions at the end.
So you hold your questions
and develop your questions.
Be listening for what do
you want to know from her?
What do you want to know
about these characters?
What do you want to know about her
writing process or whatever that is,
and we'll have time for
those questions at the end.
Okay? And with that, let me
introduce Elizabeth Wein.
Thank you so much for being here.
>> Elizabeth Wein: Hi.
Before I start, this is
a technical question.
Can you all see the screen okay?
Even you guys in the back?
You can see?
Somewhat. You're right in the front.
Oh, okay. All right.
Well, I'll try to make
it interesting even
if you can't see the screen.
I want to knowbefore I start --
because this book is set in Ethiopia
in 1935, and I want to know
if anybody here has any kind
of relationship with Ethiopia?
If you're from there, if
your parents are from there,
you have friends from there?
Your sister's from Ethiopia?
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay. Washington has got, I believe,
it's the largest Ethiopian
population outside Ethiopia,
this area does.
So it's really kind of neat for me
to be talking about this book here.
I live in Scotland where there is
pretty much no Ethiopian population
at all.
And I've lived there
since the year 2000.
So I'm assuming that's longer
than any of you have been alive.
You can't hear it in my accent.
I was raised in Pennsylvania.
But I've done a lot of traveling
in my life, and this is --
Black Dove, White Raven is --
I think it's my eighth
published novel.
Every single one of
my published novels is
about a character who's
kind of uprooted.
And I think that it's something that
I just noticed recently that I tend
to write about people who aren't
living where they originally come
from or who aren't
like the other people
where they live or
something like that.
And I think that's because I
am essentially where I live.
I'm an immigrant.
And I -- it's something I
feel very deep inside me.
So this book is based on my
family more than anything else.
These other two books that you see
up here, Code Name Verity and Rose
Under Fire are kind of World War
II adventures, and I wrote them
because I -- I got inspired
because I learned to fly in 2003.
I got a pilot's --
private pilot's license.
And I really wanted
to write about flying.
And what I ended up doing is
writing about women in aviation.
So the first book, Code Name
Verity is about a young woman
who becomes a pilot and another
young woman who is a spy.
And it's kind of an adventure story.
It's also about their
friendship during World War II.
Rose Under Fire is about another
young woman who's a pilot,
and these are all based on real
people who did real things,
and I found that as I
was writing these stories
and I feel this really talking
to a girl's school in particular,
that suddenly I've become kind of
an advocate for women in aviation.
So I have to give you my women
in aviation speech before I go
on to talk about Black
Dove, White Raven.
Have any of you ever had a flight in
a small plane like a small aircraft?
Yeah, we have one there.
How did that come about?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. Why were you -- why did
you end up in a small plane?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay, yeah.
Sometimes they put you in a little
tiny plane that only seats like 10
or 20 people or something like that.
Anybody ever been in one
that seats four people?
A grown up -- grown ups.
Yeah, whatever, you know.
No. So, how did you end
up in a small plane?
Are you a pilot?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay. It's something that I
thinnk doesn't occur to a lot
of young girls that you can
get careers in aviation.
So don't rule it out basically.
And if you want to be inspired, Code
Name Verity and Rose Under Fire are
about young women who are
flying and who are pilots.
Black Dove, White Raven also has
pilots in it, and it was kind of,
for me, a combination of
being interested in flying
and also being interested
in Ethiopia.
I -- my interest in Ethiopia
goes back to my aunt and uncle,
Susan and Roger Whitaker, who were
in the Peace Corp teaching
English there in the 1960's.
And when I finally got to go there
myself it was on a trip with my aunt
and uncle who went back for
their 35th wedding anniversary
and were nice enough
to take me with them.
So I'm going to show you --
I'm going to kind of take you
on a little bit of a tour,
especially as it seems that most
of you don't really have an
association with the country.
But I'm also going to
ask you a few questions
about what you know about Ethiopia.
This isn't a quiz.
You're not going to get graded.
So how many of you know
that Ethiopia is the only
African country never
to have been colonized?
Anybody know that?
No grownups back there
putting up their hands either.
Okay, the grownups [inaudible].
Okay, so no kids.
Ethiopia is the only African country
never to have been colonized.
The Italians invaded it in 1935.
Did you know that?
Do you know anything about
the Italian invasion?
Yes. How did you come
across that fact?
[ Inaudible ]
Did you read about it in history?
That's fantastic.
This one of your history students?
It's -- that's really good to
hear because it's a subject
that people kind of don't really
pay a whole lot of attention to,
but the Italian invasion of Ethiopia
is really considered by historians
to be kind of the first
opening sequence of World War II
because it sent a lot of messages
to the big powers of Europe.
So the fact that nobody
would stop the Italians
from attacking this country told
Hitler that they weren't going
to stop him if he attacked
countries in Europe.
It showed how powerless what were
called the great powers of Europe --
showed that they were powerless
to have any control over a country
that wanted to invade and it
also was kind of a testing ground
for Italy to use their aircraft,
which at the time were kind of state
of the art bombers, and they
went against this country
that basically had only just kind of
pulled itself out of medieval times.
The Ethiopian population
basically went barefoot.
They didn't wear shoes.
Most of them still don't wear shoes.
And even the emperor's imperial
guard didn't wear shoes.
They were using spears.
They were using antiquated rifles,
some of which were
about 60 years old.
Most of them didn't have
ammunition or they had to trade it
or make it themselves or whatever.
So these state of the art
bomber aircraft were --
and tanks and machine guns
were going against a population
that really couldn't fight back.
How many of you know about -- that
there is such a thing as poison gas
that can be used in warfare?
Yeah, lots of people.
Okay. Have you heard of mustard gas?
No? Okay. Mustard gas -- I'm
assuming if you haven't heard
of mustard gas, you also
don't know that it was used
against civilian populations in
Ethiopia during this invasion.
Have you ever heard that.
Mustard gas was used in World War I.
It was then kind of
banned for use in warfare
because it was so horrible.
So even if you have a gas mask on,
if mustard gas reaches you,
it will burn your skin.
You have to be completely
covered up to avoid it.
It also poisoned everything
around you.
So it will poison the
drinking supply.
It will poison water.
It'll poison any animals
that are around.
If you touch someone who has
been contaminated with it,
you can get burns on your hands
just from touching the person
who has been affected by it.
Here is this mustard gas
being dropped out of aircraft
on barefoot soldiers, and they
really didn't stand a chance.
So this was kind of
what I was looking
at as something I really wanted to
write about and tell people about,
but I also wanted to
tell them about Ethiopia,
which is an amazing country.
So what I'm going to show you here
is just a little bit of a background
of some of the things that I
brought into the book to make it
into a story rather then
just a history lesson.
So I needed some characters that
people were going to relate to
and I needed to -- kind
of a personal experience
that people were going to relate
to, so I drew very heavily
on my own life in writing this book.
My father used to work for the
New York City Board of Education,
and he did teach a training
in Jamaica for three years.
So between -- when I was 6 years
old, I went through grades 1
through 3 in Jamaica, and when we --
anybody here have a
relationship with Jamaica?
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Your cousin's Jamaican?
And how about you?
[ Inaudible ]
You have Jamaican cousins, too?
You.
[ Inaudible ]
Okay. We have another
Jamaican co-worker.
[ Inaudible ]
Your best friend's Jamaican?
My best friend is Jamaican,
lived in Jamaica, too.
[ Inaudible ]
Okay. So you've got Jamaican
history in your family.
[ Inaudible ]
And so do you.
Cool. One more.
[ Inaudible ]
He did? What was he doing there?
Was it just a vacation?
He was working in Jamaica?
What was he teaching?
[ Inaudible ]
Fantastic.
Oh, that's very cool.
In Kingston?
That's awesome.
Okay. So this is -- more people
have relationship with Jamaica.
It's not that far away.
And what I did was I took
my own personal experience
of being American girl in a foreign
country and kind of an alien country
and an undeveloped country and
applied that to what happens
in Black Dove, White Raven.
So it's a story of a brother and
a sister being raised together --
well, they're being raised
as brother and sister,
but they're not actually related.
One is white.
One is black.
They grow up in Pennsylvania
to about the age of 11
and then they move to
Ethiopia with their mother.
And that was the premise
for the story.
So I'm going to show
you a little bit
about myself and my Jamaican past.
I'm going to sit down
here while I do this.
And then I'm going to take you
on a very brief tour
through Ethiopia itself.
That's me in the beautiful
long blonde braids,
which I no longer have.
And that is my brother, Jared.
And they -- this is kind of --
they're two different
people that I've based --
two different couples as it
were that I based the brother
and sister [inaudible] on in the
story, and one is me and my brother
because we have a very
close relationship,
and we played together all the time,
and we made up stories together.
So there we are at
the age of 5 and 2.
And this is us in Jamaica.
I'm on the left in the pink.
Can you see Jared?
He's just sticking his head up
in the bottom right hand corner.
He was a very goofy kid.
This is taken in our
front yard in Jamaica just
in the carport with cars parked.
You can see it in the background.
The kids with us are
our nextdoor neighbors.
They are Madge, Patrick and Peaches.
And -- it is.
that was her nickname.
Her real name was Georgia,
Georgia Peaches.
And you know, it's
funny I look at her,
and I try to think how
old she is in the picture.
How old? Does anybody have a guess?
We hear like 8, 9, 12?
Okay. To me, when I
was 6 or whatever I am,
she was this like teen goddess.
She was -- even when
I look at her now,
I think she must be
about 18, but she's not.
She's much closer to
what you're guessing.
She's probably about 10.
Madge was not there.
These two are sister and brother.
Madge is their cousin, and she --
if you could see the
mountains in the background --
her family lived way
up in the mountains,
and there were no schools there.
So they sent her to live with her
cousins so she could go to school.
And we all played together, and we
made up stories together and kind
of ran riot in our
connecting backyards.
And this is a picture
that I drew at the time.
This kind of shows you how I got
into writing and making up stories.
My favorite thing to read when I
was 7 years old was a great big
collection of Buck Rogers
comic strips that dated
to the 1930's and 1940's.
And this is a picture of an episode
from one of those comic strips,
and what we have going on here
is this guy has an elaborate sort
of death thing rigged up.
So there's Buck Rogers lying there.
He's tied up by the feet to
this bent over palm tree.
This is my diseased brain
when I was 7 years old.
This tree is tied down
around this tree and held
down on this little stump here.
There's his crashed
rocket ship over there.
And then these are his
goggles, his aviator goggles
which you probably can't
see it from back there,
but there's actually a sunbeam that
is coming all the way down here
through the goggles and
setting fire to this vine.
And when the fire burns through
the vine, this tree is going
to spring up, and he's
going to be tied
but hanging upside
down, tied by his feet.
And then he's going to
be left there to die.
But of course, he isn't.
Somebody comes and rescues him,
which is always the problem
when you rigged up an
elaborate execution like this.
So that was -- we played Buck Rogers
all the time, and I actually had --
because these comics were published
in the 1930's, I was actually able
to kind of use them as I had the
kids in this book making up stories,
and they had this kind
of elaborate fantasy life
and they write stories together,
and I was actually able to use some
of the stuff that I had
enjoyed reading myself
because the time period was right.
This is a little Buck Rogers
story that I wrote when I was 7.
The original piece of paper that
this is printed on is about the size
of my hand, piece of note paper.
So this side of the paper -- this
is two sides of the same page --
this side says this is
a story of Buck Rogers.
Here's the whole story.
One day Buck was walking
with Sally and Wilma.
They were walking to a rocket ship.
That's the story.
So then it says I have
a more exciting story
on the other side of this paper.
Clearly, I knew that that just
wasn't enough to engage the reader,
and the second page is actually
a little bit more elaborate,
even though it's not original,
it was taken directly
out of the comic strips.
So there you have some background
about how my brain
worked at that time.
This is my mother and
her best friend
in Jamaica whose name is Rona.
And my mother invited Rona
to come and live with us
because she had been a maid
for an English friend of ours.
And she wasn't able to have her
less than a year old baby living
with her, and my mother
said, "Come with us.
You can bring your baby.
You can go to school."
Rona was about 19 at the time.
My mother was not a lot older.
And so Rona moved in
with us with her baby.
My mother had a baby as well.
They were about the same age.
And here they are.
So this is Rona's little
boy, Carlton.
Rona did a lot of -- she kind
of wished she had a little girl.
She did a lot of doing his
hair, really, really fancy.
And she put big bows
in his hair at times,
but this is my little sister, Maria.
They were almost exactly
the same age.
And so -- and that's me -- and so
what I was doing when I thought
of this book is I was kind
of imagining a scenario
in which these two babies
who were kind of raised --
they would get put in the
same baby buggy together,
they'd play in the same play pen,
they'd do everything together.
They thought of themselves
as brother and sister.
What would happen to them if they
grew up in a country that was
about to kind of disintegrate
into war.
And also what would happen to them
if they did actually have a chance
to grow up together as brother and
sister because these two didn't
because we left Jamaica and
Rona and Carlton stayed behind.
So that was kind of
the basis for my book.
I'm now going to whisk
you to Ethiopia.
That's me getting on an
Ethiopian Airlines plane.
And this is -- I told you I
went with my aunt and uncle.
That's them over here.
There's my Aunt Susan
and my Uncle Roger.
That's me in the middle and then
these are Susan and Roger's friends,
Elizabeth and Rick Stoner.
Rick Stoner was the head of Save the
Children in East Africa at the time.
So we all did quite a big tour,
and there is pretty
typical highland scenery.
And what I really think -- what
I'd love to show you not just
in this brief little introduction
but also in this book is
that Ethiopia is a -- it's a country
of many contrasts, but the scenes
that you see of it are kind
of fed to you by the media,
and it feels to me like there
are always scenes of poverty
and destruction and people who
are starving, and you don't get
to see the side that shows that they
have this rich cultural heritage
going back 3000 years.
They have their own ancient
language, which is the language
of the church [inaudible] and it's
-- they use it the way Latin is used
as the ancient language
of the Christian church.
They have many traditions.
As I said, they're the
only African country never
to have been colonized.
And this scene is taken in
a valley, a farming valley
where they've got an
irrigation project going,
and it's working really well.
And this is a scene
-- the largest part
of their population is Christian,
but there's also quite a large
Muslim population as well.
This is the city of Harar,
which is the holy city for Islam
in Ethiopia, and it's walled.
It's got this 1000 years
old wall around it,
which you can just
kind of make out there.
And these are kind of
typical village houses
so that's what the people in the
book would be living in except
that these are near
what's called [inaudible],
a village called [inaudible] and
for some reason or other there,
they're two stories high.
Usually, they're just
one story high.
But round stone with thatch on top.
Very typical.
And there you have the group of
traditional singers and musicians,
and this woman is doing
a coffee ceremony.
Coffee is said to have
originated in Ethiopia.
Have any of you ever went --
gone out for Ethiopian food?
Yeah? Okay.
Many more of you.
That's good because there are
quite a few excellent restaurants
in this area.
Have you seen the coffee ceremony?
Yeah? No? Okay.
Well, only a woman is
allowed to make coffee,
and in the ceremony you would boil
the coffee in this little fire pit
and -- or boil the water, and
you would roast your seeds.
There's coffee beans in it as
well and grind them yourself,
and then this is incense
because it's supposed to be --
these [inaudible] are just spread
around to create atmosphere.
It's supposed to be a calm ceremony.
It's special.
It's a time for sitting back,
and the coffee is served
in several rounds so it gets
stronger and stronger each time.
And that's a spice market.
Lots of different spices
[inaudible] there.
That's a church.
This round architecture
is kind of typical.
This is probably about
100 years old.
Some church paintings, and then
I have -- oh, this is a school.
So here you have -- here you
kind of have your counterparts.
This is a -- this school goes
up to eighth grade, I believe.
That's Rick, my uncle's
friend, Rick.
And these are staff from the school.
I believe one of them is the
head of the school and one
of them is I think maybe
the eighth grade teacher.
And then here you have some students
from the school a bit
younger than you.
This girl was pretty good at
speaking English, and they were --
we just dropped in on the school.
They didn't know we were
turning up, and they were very,
very anxious to show off what
they knew and what they could do.
They had a very high pass
rate for the national exam.
So a lot of their students went
to -- went on to high school.
And this is a school where --
I don't know if you can see,
I actually focused on the
students in the picture and not
on the extreme poverty
that they're schooling in.
Their books must be 30 years old.
Their desks are made of stone.
And when they were asked -- some of
them were asked to get up and recite
for us, and this girl stood up and
said she had a question for us,
and it was what are you
going to do for my school?
And you know, there's not a whole
lot that I can do for her school.
So the one thing I can do
is kind of show this to you
and show you how people are
learning in other countries.
Just make you a bit more
aware of other cultures.
And this is a typical improved road.
Many of the roads there are actually
funded by the Chinese government.
This is called the Chinese Road,
but you can tell it's
improved because it's graded.
It's flat, even though
it looks pretty bleak.
This was my aunt and
uncle's landlord
when they lived there in the '60's.
Still there, still
in the same house.
And this is my Aunt Susan.
We went to the town where they
lived, and we visited the school
where they taught 35 years later,
and this woman was one
of my aunt's students.
And so she had taught her
English, and she's now a teacher
in the middle school
and high school there,
which we thought was pretty neat.
And so I'm going to
finish on this picture,
which is my aunt again talking to
some of the high school students.
These girls probably are your age,
and they're the ones that have gone
on to high school, and
they're actually taught
in English at this point.
English is the language of
teaching at the high school level.
So that leaves us with five
minutes before I start asking --
well I will start asking questions.
I'm going to let you ask
me questions in a minute,
but I'm going to ask
you a few questions.
I've brought with me
some Ethiopian artifacts.
And I'm going to get them
out and show then to you.
So first of all, this is --
well obviously it's a map.
I think it's a U.S. -- I've
got to read what it says on it
so I don't give you
poor information.
Yes. It's put out by the Defense
Mapping Agency Aerospace Center.
So it's -- they put out
a big series of maps.
But this is basically a great
big enormous air defense map
of Ethiopia.
And its also got a quite a
bit of [inaudible] in it.
So if you looked at a map of the
United States or of the east coast,
there would actually be a whole
bunch of population centers in it.
And as you can see, most
of this is mountain.
All that bit is desert.
That is the [inaudible] desert.
It is the hottest place in the
world, and it's below sea level.
So that's quite a bit of
[inaudible] going on there.
Now these things --
I'll pass them around.
You can take a look.
I have some coins here.
I'm going to pass around a few of
them so you can each get a look.
But these are just regular stuff,
and this is a little
silver cross [inaudible].
I've got your hand.
Make sure everybody gets to see.
This is a little silver
cross, and these --
lots and lots of country
kids wear these.
They're made out of -- they're
hammered out of the previous coinage
which is the standard
money that they used
up until very recently was the
Maria Theresa silver dollar,
some of which were 200 years old.
A lot of them got turned
into those crosses.
Anybody have any idea
what this thing is?
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
It is made of wood.
It is a stick.
Pencil? No.
It does look line one, but it isn't.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
That's a really good guess, a coffee
stir, but that is not what it is.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
It's not a flute, no.
It's solid the whole way through.
Anybody else?
Did they get to see
this in the back?
Pass it back.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Drum stick?
Also a good guess.
It's not a musical instrument, so
it's not a flute, not a drum stick.
No, it's not for smoking.
Any other guesses?
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Use it to eat?
No. But whoever's thinking
it's something you put
in your mouth is on the right track.
Who said that?
Toothbrush is exactly what it is.
It doesn't have bristles.
It's a stick made of eucalyptus.
And this bit on the end is just
carving to make it look pretty.
This bit they've peeled the
bark off, and what you do
with it is you just stick
it in your mouth and scrape.
Eucalyptus is like mint flavor.
Eucalyptus trees grow everywhere.
They were imported, but
they grow really fast
so that means you can harvest them
really quickly, and they're used
for toothbrushes all over the place.
Do you want to pass this around?
I have one more thing
to make you guess about.
Guess.
[ Inaudible ]
It looks like a kind of
jewelry, but it isn't.
[ Inaudible ]
Used in rituals.
That is a very vague answer, so
I will say yes, you are correct .
It is used in rituals.
Did you have a guess or did
that ruin what your guess was?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. That's exactly what it is.
Wow. You guys are good.
I don't think I've ever had
anybody actually guess what these
things are.
What was your question?
[ Inaudible ]
No. They don't put toothpaste on it.
They just use it as it is.
[ Inaudible ]
I haven't because I only have
two,and I like to keep them
to show off to people
so I haven't used one.
[ Inaudible ]
I haven't even tasted it.
But you can really -- that probably
doesn't -- that's quite old.
It probably doesn't have
any kind of flavor anymore.
Have you ever picked a twig
of birch bark off a tree?
Picked a twig of birch off a tree?
Yeah, and you can chew on the
bark, and it tastes kind of minty.
No? You guys haven't lived.
[ Inaudible ]
In your mouth.
Actually, in Jamaica
we did a lot of that.
We just picked everything
and ate it.
I don't know why.
But we're still alive, so --
does it really brush your teeth?
I mean, yeah.
I think it does.
Basically, if you think about
it, what a toothbrush does,
is it just scrapes the plaque
off your teeth essentially.
So I mean, you can do
it with your fingernail.
So a piece of wood that's a little
bit flavored would do a pretty good
job of keeping your teeth clean.
So yeah, in answer to what this is,
it's used in a ritual and it is used
to stick a coffee pot in
because Ethiopian coffee pots --
and I don't know if -- let
me just ruin all the Library
of Congress' equipment.
Ethipian coffee pots I'm not
sure you can see in this --
you can't really but
you get an idea.
They're round.
They're completely round.
So it can't stand up on it.
It can't stand up on its own so it
needs -- this is called [inaudible],
but the coffee pot wouldn't.
It needs something to sit it in.
So that's exactly what that's for.
Okay, that's kind of all the
time that I have for my part
of the presentation, but now I would
love it if you had questions for me,
and we're going to pass the
microphone around to you
because this is being
recorded, and we want you
to be able to hear your question.
Okay, yeah, start over here.
>> When you were deciding
to write your book, what --
what made you come up with
the title of the book?
>> Elizabeth Wein:
Okay, that's actually --
it's not the most original
question in the world,
but it's a great question
for this book
because this has a funny
story behind the title.
I had -- it's not funny ha ha,
it's kind of funny peculiar.
For my previous book, Rose Under
Fire, I had struggled and struggled
and struggled with the title and
nobody liked the title that I liked
for it because they thought
that it sounded too much
like a fantasy novel.
I wanted to call it The Subtle
[inaudible], which was a reference
to a poem that one of the people
who was in the book had written,
and everybody said, "No, it doesn't
really match Code Name Verity.
We want these books to be connected.
It sounds too much like fantasy
so we're not going to use it."
So I had thought for this book the
characters of the children's mothers
who -- they're actually a
flying team, so they're --
in the 1920's [inaudible]
mother and M's mother perform
in flying circuses, and their
performer titles are Black Dove
and White Raven.
They are the black dove
and the white raven.
And then the kids later on take
these names and kind of turn them
into their own names and make
up these super heroes
based around them.
And I thought when I was working
on this book that Black Dove,
White Raven would be a good
title, but I didn't suggest it
because I thought everybody's
going to say that just sounds
like a fantasy title again.
So they were asking me for
titles, and I was coming
up with [inaudible] Children,The
Pilot's Children, all kinds of stuff
like this, and one of my editors
came back to me and said, "You know,
I was thinking Black Dove,
White Raven might be a really
good title for this book."
So she and I came up with the
same title completely separately.
And when she said that to me, I
was just like, "Yep, that's it."
If we both thought
of that on our own,
then that clearly is
the right title for it.
>> So I wasn't clearly
sure on what you said,
but were your little sister and
Carlton, were they like kind
of your inspiration
for the little girl?
I mean, for the --
>> Elizabeth Wein: Yeah.
I mean it was partly based on them.
I didn't actually make
that very clear.
So they lived -- they both lived
in the same house, and they played
with other and they were fed
together and they bathed together.
They did everything
together until they were two.
At which point, we left
Jamaica,taking my little sister
with us and Carlton and
Rona stayed in Jamaica
because they were Jamaican.
And these kids never
saw each other again.
So my idea was really
what would have happened
if they had grown up together?
How would their relationship
have developed?
And so that was kind of what I was
playing with when I wrote the book.
>> How long did it take you to write
the Black Dove, White Raven book?
>> Elizabeth Wein: It took about --
I think it was about
a year and a half.
It might have -- it was
about a year and a half.
It was the hardest book I have ever
written, and it was kind of behind.
I had a deadline for it, and I
kept getting them to extend it.
And I think it was
about a year and a half.
Part of the reason
it was so hard was
because I really didn't know
much about Ethiopia in 1935.
I knew a lot about Ethiopia
in the sixth century
because I'd written some
other books about it.
But I had to do a lot of research
for the background history,
and doing that and writing the book
at the same time I
found very hard work.
But it was about a year and a half.
>> Okay, so did you show your
Mom or your Dad the story?
>> Elizabeth Wein: Oh, no.
The answer to this
question is really sad
because my Mom died when I was 14.
It's all right.
It was a long time ago now.
And my father also died quite young.
So he died when I was about 20.
So neither of my parents ever
got to see my finished books.
So partly what was going on in Black
Dove, White Raven was the character
who is the mother, she's
actually a very strong character
in this book, is based on my mother.
So no, they haven't seen any
of my books, but I was --
I've really been thinking the
past week my mother would be
so proud of this book.
She was -- you guys
are really sweet.
She would just be so -- she was
a very forward thinking woman.
She loved living in Jamaica.
She was really kind of involved
in the civil rights movement
in the 1960's, and
she would be really,
really proud that this book has won
the Children's Africana Book Award
and also that I'm here talking to
you guys in the Library of Congress.
She'd be thrilled with that.
>> Okay, so out of all
the books that you made,
is there one that you
like would favor?
Is there one that's your favorite?
>> Elizabeth Wein: I don't
really like to choose favorites
because they all have kind of
different -- such different meaning.
There's so many different things
going on in them, so this is kind
of the tribute to my mother.
Rose Under Fire, the one
that I wrote before this,
was really important
to me because it was
about a woman's concentration camp
that not many people know much
about, and I felt like in writing
that book I was bringing to
a wider audience something
that needed to be told.
But Code Name Verity, it has
to be said is the book
that changed my life.
So for maybe not the right reasons,
Code Name Verity is
probably my favorite.
Without the strengths and
the success of that book,
I wouldn't be here today.
And that's really true.
So that's probably the
one that is fondest to me.
Yes. Oh, you have the mic, sorry.
>> If you saw Peaches and the
others again, what would you do?
>> Elizabeth Wein: We would
probably all start crying
and running to each other's arms.
I have actually tried to find
these people on the internet
and have not been able to.
I do actually still have
some Jamaican friends.
My best friend from school in
Jamaica now lives in England,
nd she had quite a large family
who I'm in contact with a lot.
So I do actually still have some
really good friends from Jamaica,
but this particular family
I have lost touch with.
We would -- there would
be a tearful reunion.
>> How many books have
you made so far?
>> Elizabeth Wein: Black Dove, White
Raven is my eighth published novel.
I have another one
that is in the works.
So by next year, there will be nine,
but I've written I don't know how
many more that I didn't actually --
that haven't actually
been published.
Some of them haven't been published
for kind of frustrating reasons
of marketing but most of them just
aren't good enough to be published.
So eight is the -- oh no,
that's not the easy answer
because I've forgotten.
I actually had written five
more under a pseudonym.
I always forget about
those so I don't know.
There's no easy answer
to that question,
but let's say eight
under my own name.
>> When you was little, was there
-- before when you was really little
and you started reading the
comic, was there a specific person
to inspire you to write the book
or did you just like to write?
>> Elizabeth Wein: I
really just liked to write.
So when I was reading that
comic,I wasn't thinking I want
to write stuff like this even
though I was going to write it.
I was more thinking I
want to be this person.
I was really kind of -- I was
relating to the characters.
I wanted to have adventures
and to do exciting things.
It kind of -- it was kind of tied
up in my head together wanting
to make the story but also
wanting to live that life.
And again, I think I've
put some of that in there
where particularly the
character M really relates
to her super her character,
White Raven,
and she kind of thinks what would
White Raven do all the time to try
to make herself do the right thing
or do the brave thing whatever.
So that kind of question of
identity of wanting to write
and putting yourself into a story
is something that I think a lot
of writers they kind
of go hand in hand.
Does that make sense?
Okay, good.
>> From living in Jamaica,
how would you be able
to relate it to like living here?
>> Elizabeth Wein: Living in --
okay so like the difference between
living in Jamaica and living here
or how does that influence me?
>> The difference.
>> Elizabeth Wein: The difference.
When I came -- I was
-- because I started --
can you pass the mic to the back
because I think people
there are losing out.
When I first came here,
I was 9 years old.
So I left the U.S. when I was 3, and
I didn't come back until I was 9.
So essentially my earliest
memories are not of living
in the U.S., and it was really hard.
It was really hard adjusting.
Everybody thought I'd
come from Puerto Rico.
Nobody had heard of Jamaica.
[Inaudible] in that place.
I felt like nobody understood me
and it was hard to [inaudible].
I was again an immigrant.
So that's I think one of the
reasons I do a lot of writing
about people who are displaced.
>> How -- what place is this book?
Which place is this
book influenced off of?
>> Elizabeth Wein: What was
the last part of that question?
>> So this book, which place
was it influenced from?
>> Elizabeth Wein: Oh, okay.
Well, obviously it's
set in Ethiopia,
but it was really my experience of
living in Jamaica that influenced it
because the kids in this
story, they're living
in a place that's not their own.
They're living in an
unfamiliar, very foreign country.
And they learned to
speak the local language,
but they are still
obviously foreigners.
So that kind of a relationship
with the country is something
that I drew on living in Jamaica.
But also just kind of a celebration
of the countryside because one
of the things that we did in Jamaica
I would say we ate everything.
We just -- we ran up and
down everybody's backyards
and climbed all their trees, and
we picked fruit and we just kind
of climbed on people's
roofs and just all this --
all that kind of running wild and
feeling very comfortable and at home
in the landscape is something
that was true for me in Jamaica,
and I took that and put it
in this book even though I hadn't
actually experienced living
in Ethiopia.
>> Pam Jackson: This will
be our last question.
>> Are all your books
influenced off of war in Ethiopia?
>> Elizabeth Wein: No.
My first two -- the question
was are all my books --
have they all been influenced
by the war in Ethiopia?
This is the only one
that has anything to do
with the Italian invasion
of Ethiopia.
Code Name Verity and Rose
Under Fire are both set
in Europe during World War II.
So the one thing that they all have
in common is they all have women
as pilots in them, young
women learning to fly,
which is something you'd
like to keep your minds open
and just remember that you can do
too if you ever get the chance.
And I think that unfortunately
is the last question
that you guys get to ask me.
So now I'm going to turn
it back over to Pam.
>> Pam Jackson: So please,
let's give Elizabeth
Wein a round of applause.
>> Elizabeth Wein: Can I also say
thank you to you for coming out here
and for sitting andlistening
and asking great questions
because it is the best thing about
being a writer is to get to talk
to people who are interested
in what you have to say.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.